the big question the big name the guy
that we thought was going to be the
number one overall pick in the draft at
one point but now won't be
tuatanga viloa where will he go how far
will he fall
and ultimately which helmet will he be
wearing when the time comes to wear
helmets there was a report yesterday
chris from armando saguero the miami
herald that the dolphins team physicians
came away from the scouting combine in
february convinced that tuatanga vailoa
was healthy and gave him a passing grade
on his physical
there and you know anytime i see this
kind of stuff in advance to the draft i
wonder what's the angle what's the
agenda is this just part of a broader
effort to put a little more pressure on
the bengals to want less in the event
there's a potential for a trade from
five the number one to get joe burrow
and the dolphins are taking the position
hey we don't need to do the trade we'll
just take two at five i don't know how
you can be appropriately confident now
as to what to his health is regardless
of what you saw or didn't see back in
february that's been the predominant
theme the doctors don't have the chance
before the draft to see where he is
after that fairly serious hip surgery
and i just see that as the dolphins
blowing smoke right as the dolphins
trying to make someone think they're
gonna take tour when in reality that may
not be what they're gonna do
well hey listen mike you know my
thoughts i think tua is extremely risky
and there's no way i would touch them in
the top 10.
i'm going to say i look at it a
different way here
you know and again i have a little
i've had some people within the nfl that
i trust and have steered me in the
direction the the right direction a lot
of times
and i think and again armando soguero is
very connected and he's been right about
a lot of miami dolphins things
throughout the years
to me mike i think it's almost the
opposite
i think they're getting their miami fan
base but they're just to wrap their head
around that hey our doctor said he's
okay
and we might make a play and two it
might be our quarterback with all said
and done so they want that out there
there's a thought right out there in the
nfl right now mike that
the dolphins they like herbert but they
don't love him they've always loved tua
and i just like i said yesterday was
told by some people that i trust that
they're not so sure the dolphins might
not take past the quarterback at five or
trade up the three like we're going to
talk about in a minute maybe with the
detroit lions and then
either use all three first round picks
on guys to fill spots on the team mike
and then maybe trade into the fourth
round i mean in the late into the into
the first round with a fourth
first round pick and maybe go jordan
love there mike there's a common thought
there or maybe jordan love with their
last pick in the first round uh so i i
think this could go any which way right
now and the fact
you know that you're hearing that they
might trade up to number three
that to me tells me
that it's not going to be justin urber
and they might be looking at some other
position
yeah you know you're absolutely right
that was kind of the stunner yesterday
while we were all waiting for steven
ross the owner of the team to
potentially make his move to try to get
from five to number one out came this
rumor this report this notion that the
dolphins may be trying to get to number
three in a move with the lions and
initially as it was being explained the
dolphins wanted to get the third overall
pick from the lions without giving up
the fifth overall pick they wanted to
use their two picks later in the round
as the ammunition to acquire the third
overall pick from the lions and then
have three and five and wouldn't that be
something if it happens and i couldn't
help but wonder chris
if the dolphins could pull it off where
they have number three and number five
is that then the foundation for the
offer the bengals can't refuse for
number one i still think stephen ross is
scheming for a way to get to number one
and if you can't get the bengals
attention with the picks that you
already have if you can come to the
table with three and five this year plus
maybe something else
maybe that's the way you get the bengals
to flinch on borough although at this
point i don't think it's gonna happen
no i mean i don't expect it to either
but
man if you're the cincinnati bengals and
you have a good draft grade on a guy
like justin herbert where you think a
lot of him as well
and you're getting offered a third to
five and maybe something else to go
along with it you know another high
round pick whether that's this year's
second or maybe next year second i don't
know maybe they'd be crazy to throw in
another first round pick i don't know
that would be too rich for my blood uh
but that would be something else and
that would be something that if that did
happen i think cincinnati would have to
sit there and at least contemplate it no
matter how much you love joe burrow
and this question of whether it will be
justin herbert or tuatanga viloa as the
second quarterback off the board
continues to be
muddled and confusing and that's the way
the teams want it like you said the
dolphins want us all to basically be
prepared for anything and maybe they do
want their fan base to have the
possibility in their brains if they take
tua that that's the guy they're they're
they're in a position where they should
be expecting but i feel like the
dolphins have done a great job of
creating a sense that anything can
happen and as of yesterday
via the mgm sports book justin herbert
was the betting favorite to be the
second quarterback taken and now
apparently based on
bets that were placed on tua not based
on any new information that vegas may
have it swung back to tua being the
favorite from a betting standpoint to be
the second quarterback selected and this
is all about trying to get equal betting
on each side and you don't want it to be
too skewed one way or the other and if
the bets are just flowing in on tua at
some point you have to adjust the odds
again i don't know how much vegas really
knows about when tool will go but now as
of thursday morning tua is favored to be
the second quarterback taken so you are
sticking with your thought that he's
slipping out of the top ten regardless
of whatever else may be happening i yes
i i just have a hard time you know i you
know again you know i i think the world
of a guy like brian flores you know i
don't know chris greer down there as far
as a gm but the people that i do know
that know him man i mean this is these
are smart individuals they understand
what it takes to build a football team
you know flora is coming from new
england new england typically did not
take chances on guys with such an injury
history like a guy like tua and i just
think when all said and done it's just
completely too risky yes so i i still
think he gets outside in the top ten and
then when he hits that ten mark
watch out then anything can happen it's
gonna be open business time for trading
up from somebody you know whether that's
the miami dolphins or somebody we don't
know about to make a move for tua i i
expect that to really be the case if
that doesn't happen
then you know i i don't know i am
intrigued by the dolphins i mean the
dolphins from everybody i really trust i
know they love to it and i think they
went into this process thinking they
were going to draft to it and i don't
know if the film
made them pull away a little bit to
where they were not as impressed as they
thought they might be or if it's just
the injury issue which i would imagine
that is because it's scary mike as we've
talked about many times it's a lot of
injuries there's rumors that he might
need more surgeries to clean up an ankle
you know and then i've told you about
his style of play it's a little backyard
football at times and he's not lamar
jackson or kyle or murray they're the
fastest guys on their football team
nowhere near that will be tuas type
speed and he avoids danger narrowly so
many times during the college football
season that he's scary to me that way
yeah and look i think of a guy like
patrick mahomes who isn't the fastest
guy on the team but he's elusive and i
don't know if tua is elusive enough at
the next level he wasn't and you you
made the great point throughout this
process that you see so many instances
on film where tua gets hit in a way that
you think oh no he's not going to get up
well at the nfl level you're not going
to get up if you take those awkward hits
as often as you take them at the college
level you know for the dolphins it was
tank fortua all year long and as it
turns out they ultimately didn't tank
but they still may have tua but and you
know there's another angle to this chris
because nick saban the alabama coach is
going to say what he has to say to get
to a draft of the size possible because
he wants to be loyal to his guy and he
wants to have good recruiting and i've
interviewed coaches in the past and
there's a balance the college coaches
have to strike between having
credibility with nfl coaches and taking
care of their guys but when you've got
this weird kind of love triangle between
sabin
bill belichick in new england brian
flores who was with belichick for all
those years in new england and is now in
the division and maybe circling the
possibility of taking tua
how do these relationships play out what
does bill belichick want we always view
him as this jedi master who can work
things to his advantage and whether it's
keeping josh mcdaniels around maybe for
another year based upon who gets
recommended for the giants job joe judge
not josh mcdaniels that kind of thing
what is really going on behind the
curtain as it relates to what nick saban
is or isn't saying to brian flores and
what does belichick want him to say or
not say does belichick want flores to
roll the dice onto her because he thinks
maybe tua won't be that good or is he
trying to come up with a way to get
flores to stay away from tua and and
look we know that belichick operates on
those levels so much deeper than what is
meeting the eye because that's the way
the guys always operate and it's worked
to his advantage
well yeah i mean bill yes yeah i mean
you're right bill's a mastermind he's
the wolf of wall street if he's working
on wall street that's who he is he's the
man he's just you're not going to
out-think bill you know and i know that
even the coaches on the staff in new
england i mean that was one of the first
things they kind of said to me like
nobody out thinks bill i mean and you
know when they said it i was like damn
really i mean bill's that smart and you
know you get to be around him and you're
like yeah he's he's that damn smart
there's no doubt about it now
i don't think of an organization like
new england would be into a guy like tua
you know traditionally bill belichick
has been into the traditional big
pocket passing type quarterback whether
that was when he was a defensive quarter
coordinator with my dad and it was phil
sims as the quarterback he brought
vinnie testa verdi as his quarterback
into cleveland then he was the
quarterback uh with bill parcells as the
head coach and he was the b coordinator
with the jets of course there's drew
bledsoe tom brady this guy drafted ryan
mallett rohan davey guys that really
couldn't hit the broadside of the barn
but they were big and strong and he
thought oh maybe if i can get them
accurate i can make them into something
so i just don't see tua being
this
his type of of tea his cup of tea there
mike now can i just say one more thing
because i know it's a long answer but
with like the alabama triangle like
you're talking about i do think that
comes into play right now with that pick
number three that we're hearing that
miami might trade up to get number three
with the detroit lions because i would
think joe judge of the new york giants
who coached at alabama at one point
might be sitting there going i want
jedrick wills that right tackle and i
think miami who has a desperate need to
tackle too
they also gonna go yeah i like nick
saban's tackles and the way he coaches
his offensive line too and i'm sure they
have some knowledge about it and they're
worried that ghetto men and judge are
gonna take the tackle they want at
number four and i would imagine that's
the reason they want to get up to number
three right now well an intriguing
process at the top of the draft and we
really don't know how it's going to play
out other than number one joe burrow
number two chase young after that who
knows how to transpire and let's look at
the bottom of the round you and i both
have mock drafts out there and we don't
have jordan love the quarterback from
utah state being selected now
mine specifically excluded any trades i
still think there's a chance somebody
pops back into the bottom of round one
to get jordan love that pick 32 it was
the teddy bridgewater spot it was the
lamar jackson spot it gives you five
years of contractual control with a
quarterback which is beneficial
especially if there's a chance he's
going to sit on the bench behind
somebody else for a year or two then you
have him a little bit longer do you
think there's a chance somebody
springboards back into the bottom of
round one to get jordan love
i i do i mean that was one of the things
i struggled with in my mock draft i mean
i do think there's some legitimate
interest
for jordan love i think there's a i
think there's a number of teams
really from 18 to 32 somewhere in the
teens that
you know
that are dangling the idea of maybe we
should make a play for jordan love but
ultimately i just came to the conclusion
that yes if he does go in the first
round i think it's going to be kind of
what you said mike it's going to be one
of those scenarios what maybe miami
comes away with nothing no quarterbacks
in the first round and like i said then
they start to trade up they have all
these assets and the rest of these draft
picks to maybe get back in the first
round uh for a fourth time and take
jordan love there do the indianapolis
colts get involved in this type of
conversation you know are the oakland
raiders going to be in the conversation
for jordan love you know and maybe make
a play that way uh of course the
jacksonville jaguars they could be in
that conversation in just so many ways
but you know as when it came to my own
mock mike i just you know jordan love is
he's a true project that way he needs a
year he might need two years he's really
raw mentally and physically but man his
good is really good and i think that's
what team c and that he's another one of
these you know i don't know what the
hell happens with him tonight and it's
going to be intriguing to see
you mention the colts their first round
pick is the property the 49ers because
the deforest buckner trade but they
could swoop back into round one with
their second round pick and they are a
team that is clearly looking for a
project type of a quarterback philip
rivers is the guy this year they went
rivers over tom brady in part because
brady wants more than one year with
rivers they got a one-year deal and from
their perspective it is a one-year
arrangement and they're going to go with
somebody else in 2021 so you either
draft someone in 2021 or you draft
someone now and maybe love is the guy
that chris ballard the gm of the colts
decides he needs to have another another
element that will play out as round one
unfolds tonight
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports